the energy Watchdog has reduced the
energy price cap to
3280 effective from the 1st of April
it's currently
4270. despite this bills are still
expected to rise by 20 because the
government's energy price guarantee
which caps household bills at two and a
half thousand pounds annually will rise
to three thousand pounds the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt is facing calls from
opposition parties to keep the support
at the current level in his spring
budget next month let's get more on that
uh should we
um and cuprid is here with us so the
ceilings come down but our bills are
still going to go up yeah it's a bit
complicated but when you when you add up
all the numbers it actually the result
is that households and businesses are
worse off as a result of it so this
should be good news off Jam Set
something called the energy price cap it
limits the amount that energy suppliers
can charge per unit of electricity and
gas it's announced today that up from
April that figure will be coming down so
much so that a typical household this
isn't everyone this is just a typical
household based on typical usage would
see their bills go down from 4 279
pounds a year to 3280 pounds yeah but
the government has intervened over the
past few months and set a cap of its own
so that households don't have to pay any
more at the moment than 2 500 pounds
that's rising to three thousand pounds
from April so it means all of our bills
will be going up and of course the real
winner out of all of this is the
treasury because the treasury hasn't
been absorbing that shortfall and at the
beginning of the year it thought they
would be having to Shell out about 18
billion pounds it's come right down it's
Fallen by about 90 percent so as you can
imagine there are now calls on the
chancellor to use some of those savings
that he's made to extend the support
that he's currently offering to
households so that fewer households fall
into fuel poverty and fewer businesses
go bust this means tested is it no it's
not and this is actually a really big
issue because Jeremy Hunt has made it
his stated aim to try and bring down
inflation and there's a real argument
that this support it's offered to
everyone whether you're rich or whether
you're poor it's putting more money into
people's pockets which could fuel
inflation over the coming months if you
fuel inflation that leaves everyone
worse off and some are saying that a
better policy would be a more targeted
policy so you give the money to the
people that really need it while also
keeping a lid on inflation